[موسيقى]
عندما ثقلت كنا تسعه اشخاص وبعدها اعدموا
سته منا
اعدموهم دون اي سبب لان النظام دكتاتوري
في ايران اعدمهم لمطالبتهم بالحريه كنا
فقط ندافع من اجل الحريه وهم يعلمون ذلك
ولاننا ندعم مجاهدي خلق لانهم ضد نظام
الملالي
[موسيقى]
كنت احدا الناجين من سجن افين حيث تم
الافراج عنك قبل باسابيع قليله قبل حدوث
المجزره عام 1988 هل تعتبر نفسك من
المحظوظين لانه افرج عنك قبل هذه المجزره
وتكون واحد من الضحايا ابدا لن اقول انا
محظوظ بانني لم اكن جيدا مثل بقيه
المعدومين اعتقد انني لم اكن صالحا مثلهم
[موسيقى]
الشخص الذي كان معي كان صادقا جدا لكن انا
لم اكن مثلهم
[موسيقى]
كنا سته وثمانين سجينا وفي ليله جاء
حارسان اثنان الى السجن اخذ منا خمسه
وسبعين سجينا واعدموهم مره واحده
وكان شيئا لا يصدق فنحن سته وثمانون وفجاه
خمسه وسبعون اعدموا ماذا حدث اصبت بالجنون
كنا نعلم وفهمنا انه في اي ليله سيكون
دورنا ونعدم